news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so this is unbelievable or maybe too
believable it turns out that donald
trump was never invited to throw out the
first pitch at yankee stadium
which he claims to have canceled it
appears he was simply jealous that dr
anthony fauci was invited to throw out
the first pitch at yankee stadium's
opener last week and trump first
said i will be invited and i will be
doing it soon then later he said he was
going to be too busy
this is actually the clearest
explanation this is not the most
important
news story but it puts together a bunch
of really important things one of which
is donald trump's
jealous disdain for dr anthony fauci
which led to trump tweeting nonsense
about fouchy in the middle of the night
last night
trump completely lacking focus on
anything important
during a pandemic while he's golfing
tweeting
and being jealous of anthony fauci and
thinking about first pitches
but let's get caught up first so we all
know what we're talking about last week
donald trump claimed he would be
throwing out a first pitch
at yankee stadium on august 15th
trump then tweeted canceling it saying
quote because of my strong focus on the
china virus including scheduled meetings
on capital v vaccines our economy and
much else
i won't be able to be in new york to
throw out the opening pitch for the
yankees on
august 15th we will make it later in the
season and i speculated
trump's worried he'll look stupid
because he looked really dumb throwing a
baseball around last week he doesn't
want to be ridiculed for a bad first
pitch
or trump doesn't want to get booed like
he's been booed at other stadiums which
was just wrong of me to say because
there's no crowds right now at baseball
games
or trump doesn't want to be rebuked by
all of the players because
overwhelmingly major league baseball
players have been kneeling during the
national anthem
if trump's there while that's going on
that's not going to look particularly
good for trump
i was over analyzing the truth is there
was no first pitch
there was no first pitch to cancel trump
made it all up when trump announced this
his own staff knew there was no such
thing on his schedule
the yankees knew there was no such thing
on their schedule what happened was that
trump was so
jealous of anthony fauci that he told
his staff call up my friend at the
yankees
and tell him i want to throw out a first
pitch there was no actual date
behind the scenes chaos ensued and
ultimately trump ended up canceling an
event
that never even existed with the tweet
that i showed you earlier
and it all goes back to trump's
uncontrollable
jealousy it's really envy of dr fauci
when trump said he was invited to throw
out the first pitch
it was an hour before dr fauci actually
threw out the first pitch fragile trump
was triggered and was just lying that's
it that's the explanation
should this surprise us no the lying
certainly should not
trump likes uh uh to lie regularly about
easily disproven things you know the
size of his
crowd coronavirus testing he lies all
the time about everything
the really dangerous part is the
weaponized
jealousy of dr fauci fauci's a doctor
and trump isn't
and yet trump is in some kind of bizarre
competition with fouchi
as if they have equally valid opinions
on medical issues which
they don't i should i can't believe i
have to clarify that but
they don't trump is petty to the point
of being delusional
and that has been normalized over the
last three years remember when trump
tweeted
you know time magazine it was something
like time magazine called me and said i
was probably going to be man of the year
person of the year whatever last year
but i would have to agree to do like an
interview in a major photo shoot
and it's i'm just too busy so i passed
completely made up i mean just
fabricated out of thin air then trump
ended up being mad
that greta tunberg ended up being times
person of the year
it's all insane it is weaponized envy
it is delusional ignorance uh it is
a global laughing stock and we i'm not
even going to say it you know what we
have to do
we do it in three months and then we
move on and we start returning to
normality normalcy normality i prefer to
say normality despite it maybe not being
a word